j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir bruno david
directeur de recherche au cnrs et
président du muséum d'histoire naturelle
christophe volèrent titulaire depuis
février dernier de la chaire consacrée à
la biodiversité au collège de france et
par visioconférence
valérie masson-delmotte climatologues
directrice de recherche au cea et membre
du haut conseil pour le climat
madame messieurs au nom de la commission
nous vous remercions de nous faire
partager l'indispensable travail de
recherche que vous accomplissez et les
constats que vous en retirez comme le
rappelait max weber le savant et le
politique évolue dans deux sphères
différentes
soyez donc sincèrement remercier de
venir dans notre assemblée parlementaire
pour y apporter vos éclairages et vos
connaissances si précieuse pour la
vitalité de notre démocratie
nous prenons très au sérieux le rôle de
constituants que nous endossons dans le
cadre de l'examen de ce projet c'est
pourquoi nous souhaitons
bush interrogé sur ce que la recherche
scientifique la plus récente nous
apprend de l'érosion de la biodiversité
des menaces que cette érosion fait peser
en france et dans le monde ainsi que des
effets présents et à venir du
dérèglement climatique
ceux qui sont d'ores et déjà certains
est ce qu'il est encore possible
d'éviter ou d'atténuer commençons par
les questions sémantique la diversité
biologique et elle strictement
équivalente à la biodiversité les
notions de dérèglements changement de
réchauffement climatique sont
fréquemment employé laquelle ne
devrait-on privilégiées
quelle signification revêt selon vous
l'expression de préservation de
l'environnement
le jean s'agir fait l'objet d'un
consensus qui paraissait inimaginable il
ya encore d'une vingtaine d'années mais
quelle forme de reprendre cette action
la constitutionnalisation de ces deux
objectifs
répond elle à cet impératif quel serait
selon vous les meilleures voies d'action
en somme
quels conseils la science
tel souffle et au droit en 2004 la
charte avait été rédigé par une
commission de scientifiques et de
juristes présidée par le professeur yves
coppens
aujourd'hui l'évolution
constitutionnelle proposée émane du
travail de 150 citoyens tirés au sort
sans compétences spécifiques a priori ni
scientifique il est important que l'on
entende l'espère tease scientifique et
c'est également l'un des objectifs de
cette table ronde
madame messieurs vous avez la parole je
commencerai par un problème qui est
l'amnésie environnementale qu'on a
notamment face à la biodiversité encore
plus que par rapport au climat
pourquoi tout simplement parce que on a
tous en mémoire des événements
climatiques extrêmes la tempête de 99
des inondations catastrophiques dans la
vallée de la roya par exemple l'automne
dernier un épisode de chaleur de
canicule en 2019
on a on a sans mémoire pour la
biodiversité si je vous dis qu'on a plus
de 50% des moineaux qui ont disparu de
cale de paris des rues de paris en 15
ans on ne note pas simplement parce que
c'est une érosion qui se passent
progressivement et qu'il y a toujours
des moineaux et que nous en voyons
toujours et cette amnésie
environnementale qui est très forte pour
les biodiversité c'est un petit peu
comme quand on se regarde dans le miroir
le matin on a l'impression d'avoir
toujours le même visage que la veille ce
qui est pas totalement faux sauf si on a
fait des excès particulier mais si on
prend une photo d'il ya une quinzaine
d'années on se dit ouh là là quand même
j'ai un peu changé et cette amnésie qui
concerne la biodiversité c'est un petit
peu la même chose
alors pourquoi on est face à cette
amnésie
mais finalement parce que percevoir la
biodiversité c'est pas si simple que
cela
c'est un terme qui paraît simple parce
que le vocable lui-même est simple fait
d'avoir savoir qu'il est récent il a été
forgée en 1988 et il a eu son succès à
partir de rio 1992
mais derrière ce constat ça peut être à
la fois la richesse c'est à dire combien
on a d'espèces sous les yeux combien
at-on d'espèces quand on regarde un
écosystème un paysage un jardin
ça peut être bien sûr derrière les
richesses les abondances combien gdz
individus de chacune de ces espèces
si je vous complique un peu les choses
ça peut être des rapports d'abondance
est ce que j'ai pas une espèce qui est
très dominante avec des espèces rares ou
est-ce que le contraire j'ai des
abondances équilibré on peut peser ces
individus il ya des petites espèces il
ya des grosses d'espèce on parle en
biomasse si on regarde la biomasse de la
diversité terrestre aujourd'hui c'est
avant tout des plantes des plantes et
des microbes en gros et les zooms des
animaux là dedans pèse pour beaucoup
moins lourd et si on fait un zoom sur
les animaux sont essentiellement des
insectes enfin des arthropodes en
général des mollusques et si on fait
encore un zoom sur les mammifères dont
on s'aperçoit que nos mammifère
domestique pèse pour dix fois plus lourd
même vingt fois plus lourd que les
mammifères sauvages
aujourd'hui donc ça donne aussi une
mesure de l'emprise de l'homme sur la
planète on peut regarder les gènes on
peut regarder des réseaux d'interactions
entre des espèces ce qui m'amène à vous
parler des équilibres au sein des
écosystèmes les écosystèmes sont dans
des équilibres qu'on peut qualifier et
domeo statique c'est à dire qu'ils vont
revenir à un état d' équilibre même si
on les perturbe
mais jusqu'à un certain un certain point
au delà d'un certain point quand un
niveau un seuil est dépassé
l'éco système bascule dans un nouvel
équilibre est l'exemple que j'en donne
souvent c'est l'exemple de la tour
eiffel vous pouvez enlever des
poutrelles de la tour eiffel sens
qu'elle s'effondre
puis au bout d'un moment vous enlevez
une poutrelle de trop et la tour eiffel
va s'effondrer
vous aurez toujours une tour eiffel qui
sera un tas de ferraille sur le champ de
mars qui vous rendra simplement plus les
mêmes services avec quand ce n'est qu'au
système c'est un petit peu pareil vous
pouvez enlever des espèces de
l'écosystème et puis au bout d'un moment
vous enlevez l'espèce de trop et vous
retrouvez avec un écosystème qui vous
rend plus le même service les la
biodiversité je vous dirais c'est assez
compliqué on peut l'approcher avec
différents regards ça veut dire qu'on
peut pas faire de prédictions on est
dans un monde qui est non déterministe
on n'est pas dans le monde de la chimie
de la physique
on sort de ça on est dans le monde de
l'évolution biologique
on est dans le monde d'une histoire est
par définition ça n'est pas prêt dit bhl
prédictible on n'est plus dans ce monde
déterministe ça veut dire qu'il faut
être modeste qui ne faut pas être
arrogant qui ne faut pas penser qu'on va
pouvoir gérer la biodiversité
je peux vous donner simplement un
exemple on est capable d'envoyer
persévérance sur mars
c'est un exploit fantastique on est dans
le monde de la physique c'est à peu près
déterminé à part si un caillou qui fait
basculer le robot le véhicule martien on
est à peu près dans un monde déterminer
la biodiversité vous avez peut-être
entendu parler des punaises de lit qui
reviennent dans nos villes et dans nos
hôtels qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'était
un fléau qui c'est qui existaient
pendant des siècles
et puis après la deuxième guerre
mondiale on avait réussi à aller on a
commencé d'éradiquer ces punaises de lit
en utilisant des insecticides assez
puissant dont du ddt mais moi quand
j'étais jeune dans les années 70 80 90
je lui en parlez pas des punaises de lit
et puis là ils reviennent et qu'est ce
qu'on a fait finalement pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle revienne on a simplement exercé
une sélection darwinienne sur les
punaises de lit on à sélectionner celles
qui étaient les plus résistantes aux
insecticides et maintenant on est face à
des punaises résistante donc là c'est
simple c'est un problème qui est très
simple on a manipulé en quelque sorte
une espèce qui l a fait quelque chose
blake auquel on s'attendait pas à
laquelle on s'attendait pas donc soyons
modestes alors ça veut dire mais comment
est ce qu'on peut penser des futurs
possibles si on est face à cette
complexité
on a besoin d'un cadre pour penser ce
futur ses futurs possibles
d'abord il faut savoir penser plus loin
que ce que nous sommes plus loin que la
microseconde financière mais même peu
plus loin que qu'un mandat électoral
même de sénateurs de 9 ans c'est plus
que six ans maintenant ah oui c'est vrai
que c'est renouvelable par tiers etc
touré dit
je vous plains je vais vous plaindre je
vais vous plaindre je croyais jamais
j'en étais resté à 9 ans vous voyez donc
oui on peut penser sa vie on peut se
projeter sur 10 ans 20 ans 30 ans on
peut on peut imaginer la vie de ses
enfants
mais en fait le temps de l'écologie
c'est plutôt miloudi milan s'entend à la
rigueur le temps de l'évolution c'est
plutôt 10 mille ou cent mille ans est
fausse apprend il faut essayer penser ce
genre d'horizon si on veut arriver à
vivre correctement sur terre je
rappellerai simplement que si on ramène
l'histoire de la vie à une année avec
l'origine de la vie au 1er janvier la
naissance de jésus-christ notre ère 2021
c'est 2021 une année elles tiennent dans
les vingt dernières secondes de l'année
dire qu'on fait naître jésus-christ si
on prend cette référence le 31 décembre
à 23 heures 59 minutes 40 secondes et ça
veut dire du haut de ses vingt secondes
on s'arroge le droit de tout tripoter et
de faire des choses sur dans un monde
non déterministe qui peut nous échapper
donc ça veut dire qu'on a besoin de
connaissances ça veut dire qu'on a
besoin d'histoire naturelle et
l'histoire naturelle c'est aussi une
école d'observation qui aident à forger
des citoyens responsables qui elle qui
aide à respecter les faits qui ne
supporte pas les fai alternatifs donc
c'est une démarche intellectuelle
importante mais c'est pas suffisant on a
besoin aussi de sciences humaines et
sociales pour aborder ces questions qui
sont des questions complexes et on ne
résoudra pas des questions complexes
sans sciences humaines et sociales on a
besoin de l'acceptabilité de nos
sociétés face à des mesures qu'on
pourrait prendre
on a vu avec 6 centimes d'augmentation
du gasoil ce que donnaient les lits
gilet jaune donc on voit bien qu'il ya
des murs d'acceptabilité qui sont
éventuellement difficile à franchir il
faut réussir à convaincre si les enjeux
sont compris accepter ça permet de
franchir éventuellement ses murs
d'acceptabilité et puis on a besoin de
rationalité parce qu'il faut de la
rationalité scientifique il faut rejeter
les fai alternatifs comme on dit
maintenant pour parler de mensonge
ça veut dire et en tant que président du
musée on se pose la question de comment
parler de science à des gens qui sont de
moins en moins la culture et à la
science et à ce domaine donc comment
transmettre aussi des paroles
scientifique
et je suis ravi que nous accueillons
aujourd'hui pour pour y participer pour
y contribuer et puis si je peux terminer
par une note un petit peu plus
philosophique longtemps l'homme c'est
penser en dehors du reste de la planète
dans une forme de dualisme entre les
hommes d'un côté puis on regardait la
nature de l'homme il y avait les hommes
et la nature
et puis on a lutté contre la nature
pendant des générations et des
générations et au muséum on a très belle
statue du 19e siècle qu'on envoie un
orang outan en train d'étrangler un
homme enfin on a des mises en scène
absolument spectaculaire on voit bien
que l'homme lutter contre la nature
puis on s'est penché au sommet de la
nature en se disant cette pauvre nature
il faut qu'on s'en occupe et il ya
toujours cette tentation de gestion
d'ailleurs qui subsistent et maintenant
on réalise vraiment et scientifiquement
on en être convaincu depuis pas mal
d'années maintenant que nous sommes dans
la nature nous faisons partie de la
nature notre espèce répartis de la
nature nous sommes en relation avec le
reste de la nature nous sommes rien sans
le reste de la nature donc il faut qu'on
sorte de ce dualisme mais néanmoins je
voudrais pas qu'on en sorte à 100% je
voudrais qu'on rajoute une pincée
dualiste comme en rajoute un petit peu
de sel dans une recette de cuisine un
tout petit peu de dualisme quand même
parce que si on est si on sort
complètement de ça on peut être
complètement déresponsabiliser
simplement en disant qu'après tout c'est
pas de notre faute à un les castors font
des barrages et ben nous on fait des
fusées et puis c'est comme ça et c'est
le jeu de l'évolution qui nous a amenés
à faire tout cela on peut avoir une
attitude extrêmement cynique extrêmement
détaché en dix ans après tout c'est
l'espèce humaine elle fait ce qu'elle a
à faire mais notre conscience nous donne
aussi la conscience de ce que nous
sommes en train de faire et de l'impact
de ce que nous faisons sur le reste du
vivant et sur nous mêmes aussi parce que
comme nous avions besoin du reste du
vivant c'est aussi de nous même qu'il
faut se protéger
donc sortir du dualisme tout en ayant
quand même une responsabilité et la
vraie question c'est une formule que je
tiens mes prédécesseurs au muséum c'est
l'homme sera-t-il s'adapter à lui même
donc tentons de nous adapter à nous
mêmes donc c'était un panorama
extrêmement général et je pense que mes
collègues vont être plus pertinente mois
sur un à la fois sur la biodiversité sur
le climat dont je n'ai pas parlé du tout
d'ailleurs
merci pour ces explications et merci
pour la formule je serai un jour de la
glisser quelque part maintienne notre
formule sur l'homme
l'homme sera t'il s'adapter à lui même
je cède la parole donc tu continues j'ai
aussi quelques dire positif je sais pas
s'ils vont passer vont passer en tout
cas merci pour l'accueil ce plaisir
d'être là avec nous aujourd'hui
[Musique]
alors l'une des façons dont la science
tente de projeter l'avenir est de
regarder dans le passé
en ce qui concerne la biodiversité nous
pouvons examiner les changements
survenus au cours de l'histoire profonde
la vie sur terre voire comme mon avis a
évolué et s'est complexifié il est clair
que cette histoire n'a pas été une
promenade sur une fleuve tranquille mais
qu'elle a plutôt été ponctuée de
plusieurs événements d'extinction
massive à l'échelle planétaire
nous pouvons examiner ces événements et
essayez donc comprendre les causes et il
en ressort que la relation entre le
climat est le monde vivant est
extrêmement étroite
ils sont en fait fortement lié et on on
une série de dépendance réciproque
chacun des cinq chacun des cinq grands
événements d'extinction massive est
généralement associée à une dérégulation
du cycle de carbone en particulier la
répartition entre le co2 dans
l'atmosphère
la quantité de carbone dans la matière
organique c'est la partie biologique et
la quantité qui est séquestrée dans la
terre c'est la partie géologique sous la
forme de carbonate calcaire par exemple
est de combustibles fossiles tout de
générés par les organismes vivants
je lui rappelle
dont pratiquement tous les cas
d'extinction massif les quantités
relative de carbone dans ses réservoirs
sont perturbées par exemple pas des
activités volcaniques qui libèrent
rapidement des camps de grandes
quantités de carbone ont fui dans
l'atmosphère ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui est assez simple à
comprendre dans ce contexte en libérant
de carbone qui étaient séquestrés dans
la terre depuis des millions d'années
nous libérons d'énormes quantités de co2
dans l'atmosphère et pourquoi
le co2 est il important c'est parce que
est ce qu il se comporte comme gaz à
effet de serre dans l'atmosphère
reichshoffen ainsi l'avant ce faire
parce que ici du soudan l'eau et
provoquent l'acidification des océans
il est remarquable de constater que nous
augmentons probablement le 6 août à des
taux plus élevés que lors de toutes les
extinctions massives dans le passé basé
sur la situation actuelle de 417 ppm de
co2 dans l'atmosphère
nous estimons que beaucoup d'espèces
sont en danger
ils sont en danger et 10 6 240 à cinq
cent quarante ans on prévoit que nous
aurons des taux d'extinction planétaire
supérieure à 75 % les taux le taux qui
définit une extinction massive
donc ce n'est pas demain mais c'est mais
c'est pas trop loin et c'est clair que
les générations futures vont nous juger
pour ce qu'on fait ce que nous on va
faire face à sète ce problème
nous sommes donc devenus une énorme
puissance capable d'influer sur le
fonctionnement du système terrestre
aussi puissante que des centaines de
vols massifs ne sont pas le premier la
première espèce a provoqué une
extinction de masse les microbes qui
produisent du méthane ou de sophie
d'hydrogène et ont contribué dans le
passé l évolution est la propagation des
plantes sur terre ont probablement
provoquer une élimination massive de co2
dans l'atmosphère par le biais de la
photosynthèse ce qui a considérablement
réduit les températures à l'échelle
planétaire la différence bien sûr est
que contrairement aux microbes et aux
plantes nous sommes conscients des
dommages que nous causons nous essayons
d'y rémédier 2010 est très bien ou non
les décennies prochaines seront
critiques
la lutte pour l'action sara sont
difficiles et acharné et quel que soit
le résultat obtenu
il est déjà trop tard pour éviter de
graves perturbations du climat mondial
le changement individuel est nécessaire
mais le changement systémique
les couteaux volent tout autant nous
devons donc faire preuve de la volonté
politique nécessaire
est ce à l'échelle mondiale l'échelle du
problème signifie que nous avons besoin
de solutions à une échelle équivalente
nous aurons besoin de remettre technique
aux problèmes environnementaux
mais envisager des solutions spécifiques
à chaque problème environnemental est
problématique car cela tente c'est
pareil ce qui est en réalité
interconnectés et masques ainsi les
véritables problèmes les plus profondes
du système mondial la culture écologique
ne doit donc pas être réduite à une
série de réponses urgentes et partielle
aux problèmes immédiats de la pollution
de la dégradation de l'environnement de
la poudre l'épuisement des ressources
naturelles également l'ampleur du
problème est trop importante pour que
nous puissons puis si on rêvait de
revenir en arrière et que chacun ce
canton ce canton de manger des carottes
bo l'environnement est et si massivement
modulée par nous que même la
préservation d'une lieue implique des
interventions comment la science tente
elle de trouver les réponses pour deux
thèmes des tables problème le système
alimentaire et agricole mondiale qui
représente le plus grande menace pour la
biodiversité la terre est aussi notre
opportunité d'améliorer notre rapport
avec l'environnement le développement
durable de l'agriculture qui comprendra
le maintien ou l'augmentation des
rendements agricoles durables tout en
protégeant et en restaurant les habitats
naturels sera essentiel pour andré et
inverser la perte de biodiversité nous
avons vous à plusieurs reprises la crise
la biodiversité recul la crise du climat
le changement climatique s'il n'est pas
maîtrisé risque de dépasser le
changement d'affectation des terres
comme première cause de perte de
biodiversité
il est possible de contribuer à la
résolution de cette crise
en utilisant de manière appropriée au
niveau local des solutions fondées sur
la nature pour atténuer le changement
climatique et renforcer la résilience à
celui ci tout en améliorant la
biodiversité
elle est bien être humain comme la crise
de covile 19 nous l'a montré cruellement
nous avons encore beaucoup de barrières
à faire tomber avant que la science et
la politique ne trouve moyen efficace de
dialoguer il y à mouvement très
dangereux vers l'antiscience en france
ces jours ci ce n'était pas comme ça
avant lorsque je suis arrivé en france
il ya vingt ans les conditions pour
faire de la recherche fondamentale était
très favorable depuis mon arrivée j'ai
observé les régions de la science
fondamentale en france dans le même
temps j'ai constaté une montée de la
résistance à la technologie qu'il
s'agisse de l'énergie nucléaire des ogm
dans l'agriculture est maintenant le
mouvement antivaccin
aucune de ces discussions n'est noire ou
blanche à l'exception de la vie dont
nécessité pour nous tous de recevoir le
vaccin
tiko vide pour sûreté de la crise
actuelle mais chaque discussion doit
être informée par les meilleures preuves
scientifiques rationnelle disponibles
issues de la méthode conscience
consensuelle dans laquelle la science
avance le sentiment anti scientifique
actuelle en france est très mauvais pour
l'avenir technologie technologique du
pays
le soutien doit revenir la science
fondamentale cela doit se faire au
niveau politique par le soutien
financière cru bien sûr mais aussi par
des investissements dans l'enseignement
des sciences
c'est particulièrement vrai dans le
domaine des sciences de l'environnement
pour laquelle il faut augmenter
drastiquement le rythme des découvertes
face à la crise actuelle de la
biodiversité et de dérèglement
climatique
le mba à heidelberg l'institut de
recherche le plus important dédié à la
recherche biologique en europe
c'est l'équivalent du cern à genève se
consacre à cette vision proposons
d'ouvrir une toute nouvelle division en
biologie planétaire qui montrait de la
donne dans l'avis positif
donc il faut que la france en reste elle
aussi dans la même manière
merci pour votre attention
merci
je retiendrai aussi quelque chose c'est
que vous avez je pense que c'est
important dans cette dans cette loi pour
qu'on réagit sur ce sujet c'est vous
avez dit à un moment donné le changement
individuel est nécessaire et je crois
que effectivement on peut mettre en
place un certain nombre de jours vouloir
un certain nombre de choses mais si
individuellement on se remet pas en
cause on se dit pas on a d'un certain
nombre d'attitudes a changé je crois que
c'est parce qu'on n'y arrivera pas ramé
sera beaucoup plus compliqué je vous
sais de la parole madame masson delmotte
oui bonjour et merci beaucoup de m'avoir
permis d'intervenir depuis sa clé à
distance donc cette brève présentation
que je vais faire s'appuie sur l'état
des connaissances scientifiques
vis-à-vis du changement climatique en
particulier sur la base des trois
rapports spéciaux du giec de 2018 et
2019 qui ont passé en revue près de
20000 publications scientifiques
récentes donc par la combustion
d'énergies fossiles charbon pétrole gaz
par les changements d'utilisation des
terres les activités agricoles et
industrielles
les activités humaines perturbe
profondément la composition de
l'atmosphère et il est certain qu'elles
sont responsables d'une hausse continue
des niveaux de gaz à effet de serre
depuis la révolution industrielle ce qui
est une rupture par rapport aux
variations naturelles du derniers
millions d'années des activités humaines
conduisent donc un déséquilibre du bilan
d'énergie de la terre par cet essai de
serre supplémentaires est un petit peu
masquées par l'effet parasols
refroidissant duo roger de particules de
pollution
les facteurs qui agissent le plus sens
sur le réchauffement climatique sont les
rejets de dioxyde de carbone co2 et de
méthane
le gaz naturel les rejets mondiaux de
co2 qui sont de l'ordre de 42 milliards
de tonnes par an un modifie profondément
le cycle du carbone à l'échelle
planétaire sur ce qu'on est dans
l'atmosphère environ 30% et repris par
la végétation et des sols et environ 25%
par l'océan ce qui conduit à modifier la
chimie de l'eau de mer sont
acidification les 45% de nos émissions
qui s'accumulent dans l'atmosphère
chaque année celle qui reste une fois
que
puis naturelles ont fait leur travail
vont continuer à agir sur le climat à
l'échelle de centaines et de milliers
d'années le déséquilibre du bilan
d'énergie de la terre donc la chaleur
qui ne part plus vers les palais qui ne
part plus vers l'espace
cela conduit à une accumulation
d'énergie le réchauffement à la surface
de la terre est l'un des indicateurs de
cet état du climat qui change
il dépasse maintenant un degré par
rapport à 1850 1900 il est plus marquée
en france en plus de 1 degré et demi
comme sur tous les continents et il est
particulièrement intense en autour de
l'arctique du fait de processus
amplificateur par rapport à l'énergie
supplémentaire qui a accumulé ce
réchauffement de l'air ne représente
qu'un pour cent de cette énergie
supplémentaire 3% conduit à la fonte du
manteau neigeux au dégel des sols gelés
à la fonte de la banquise arctique des
glaciers la fonte du groenland et un
écoulement plus rapide de certains
secteurs des glaces continentales de
l'antarctique 5% de l'énergie
supplémentaire en train d'un
réchauffement des sols et le plus gros
de l'énergie supplémentaire près de 90%
rentrer dans l'océan qui se réchauffe en
surface puis en profondeur compte tenu
du temps de mélange d eau dans l'océan
mondial qui est de l'ordre du millier
d'années cela rend le changement
climatique actuel qui est le résultat
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
pas c'est irréversible
aucun secteur naturel situation de
l'activité du soleil effet des éruptions
volcaniques ou variabilité spontanée du
climat explique cette accumulation
d'énergie et l'ensemble de ses
caractéristiques et du réchauffement
ce réchauffement est aussi une rupture
par rapport à l'histoire du climat au
cours des derniers millénaires
la meilleure estimation à ce jour et que
100 % avec une plage d'incertitude de
l'ordre de 20% du réchauffement observé
à la surface de la terre et dual
influence humaine sur le climat le
déséquilibre du bilan d'énergie de la
terre en train d'un ensemble de
conséquence modification de la
circulation atmosphérique modification
de la répartition de la pluviométrie en
fait intensification du cycle de l'eau
augmente à
des records de précipitations parce
qu'une atmosphère un degré plus chaude
le contenir 7 % d'humidité en plus quand
sa trajectoire lui permet de se remplir
d'humidité augmentation dans certaines
régions comme en france tout autour de
la méditerranée de l'occurrence de
sécheresse en quarts une atmosphère plus
chaude favorise aussi à une vidange plus
rapide des sols par l'évaporation et la
transpiration des plantes une
conséquence directe qui ont aussi à
l'augmentation de la fréquence et
l'intensité des extrêmes chaud et une
baisse pour les extrêmes froid le
réchauffement conduit aussi à une
augmentation des conditions favorables
aux incendies de forêt sur une saison
plus longue des surfaces plus large et
il augmente la proportion des cyclones
tropicaux les plus intenses la montée du
niveau des mers est une conséquence
directe du réchauffement du fait que
l'océan gonfle en se réchauffant et par
la fonte des glaciers du groenland et
l'écoulement plus rapide de secteurs de
l'antarctique qui rajoute en fait en
deux lots à l'océan d'ailleurs
l'accélération du rythme de montée du
niveau des mers depuis les années 90 est
dû au début de la réponse du groenland
et de l'antarctique la hausse graduelle
du niveau des mers entraîne aussi une
augmentation des événements de très haut
niveau marin lié aux submersions côtière
quand cela s'ajoute aux épisodes de
tempêtes et aux épisodes de marie dans
de nombreuses régions du monde les
niveaux extrêmes marin qu'il était
atteint qu'une fois par siècle au cours
du siècle dernier seront atteint parfois
chaque année d'ici à 2050 les enjeux
pour le littoral pour les zones de basse
terre sont majeurs plus le niveau de
réchauffement à la surface de la terre
sera élevé plus ses multiples
conséquences affecteront chaque région
avec des effets composite des tendances
des extrêmes des valeurs au dessus de ce
seuil de tolérance seuil de tolérance
pour les écosystèmes ou pour nos
infrastructures
chaque fraction de réchauffement
supplémentaire compte par rapport aux
risques liés au climat qui résulte à la
fois de ce climat qui change mais aussi
des vulnérabilités et de l'exposition
aux aléas climatiques
ferry ce que touche à des enjeux majeurs
pour la préservation des écosystèmes et
pour la sécurité humaine pour des droits
humains
d'un manteau chaque fraction de
réchauffement supplémentaire augmente
les risques de dégradation sévère pour
les récifs de coraux tropicaux du fait
des vagues de chaleur marine mais aussi
des risques de perte d'habitat pour de
nombreuses espèces du fait de
déplacement des zones climatiques ou
bien les risques de dépérissement de
forêt du fait de conditions plus chaudes
et plus sèche le niveau de réchauffement
est directement liée à une augmentation
de risques liés aux inondations côtières
lui vial il ya des enjeux en matière de
santé publique du fait par exemple de la
morbidité et de la mortalité lié à la
chaleur extrême
le niveau de réchauffement affectent un
certain rendement agricole qui ont par
exemple des seuils pour certains niveaux
de température et ensuite chutant pour
des céréales clé pour la productivité
des animaux d'élevage et du coup je vais
mettre l'accent sur l'utilisation des
terres les terres c'est une ressource
critique est sous pression croissante du
fait de l'évolution de la démographie
dans le monde mais aussi de la
consommation alimentaire qui conduit on
a entendu tout à l'heure à une
dégradation des écosystèmes terrestres
et le changement climatique ajoute à ces
pressions empire une situation tendue et
menace la sécurité alimentaire les
risques en matière d' instabilité
d'approvisionnement alimentaire augmente
très fortement
même pour un niveau de réchauffement
proche du niveau actuel et les risques
en matière d'insécurité alimentaire
dépendent à la fois du niveau de
réchauffement mais aussi des choix
socio-économiques
si on met l'accent sur la soutenabilité
par une gestion durable des terres du
foncier par des modes de production et
d'alimentation résilient diversifiée par
une élimination de l'extrême pauvreté
en fait cela permet de limiter les
risques en matière d'insécurité
alimentaire
mais à l'envers sein des choix socio
économiques qui renforcent les
inégalités la pression sur les terres
des modes de production et de
consommation très intensif en ressources
au contraire renforce l'effet du
changement climatique pour les risques
en termes de sécurité alimentaire les
risques liés au climat sont
disproportionnellement plus élevés dans
certaines régions autour de l'arc
iq pour les régions semi arides et de
climat méditerranéen pour les zones de
basse terre les deltas les petites îles
nos territoires d'outre-mer sont
particulièrement concernés et pour les
pays les moins avancés rien contre un
degré et demi et 2 degrés de
réchauffement donc proche du niveau
actuel on parle en scène de plusieurs
centaines millions de personnes
centaines de millions de personnes qui
sont susceptibles de basculer dans la
pauvreté et qui seraient exposés à des
risques climatiques croisés en cascade
est croissant pourquoi est ce qu'on
parle des effets en cascade parce qu'il
ya bien sûr les effets directs d'un
climat qui change sur les aléas les
milieux physiques mais il ya les effets
indirects sur les écosystèmes dont nous
dépendons
alors je vais mettre l'accent sur
l'océan et la cryosphère la cryosphère
c'est tout ce qui est enneigée et ont
glacé l'océan et la cryosphère ont pris
de plein fouet les conséquences du
changement climatique avec des
conséquences profondes et gravant aussi
bien pour la nature que pour l'humanité
c'est le cas dans les régions de
montagne du fait du recul des glaciers
du recul de l'enneigement du dégel des
sols gelés qui affecte les aléas
naturels locaux les écosystèmes et les
activités locales pour les loisirs le
tourisme mais aussi les rendements
agricoles le patrimoine et l'identité
culturelle ainsi que les activités en
aval tout particulièrement concernant la
disponibilité en eau pour les villes
l'agriculture mais aussi la production
hydroélectrique d'hydroélectricité par
exemple vous voyez que nous avons mis en
mouvement les composantes les plus
lentes du système climatique l'océan les
calottes polaires la montée du niveau
des mers est inéluctable quoi qu'on
fasse
elle va se poursuivre à l'échelle de
siècle et deux millénaires mais son
rythme va dépendre du niveau de
réchauffement les risques liés à cette
montée du niveau des mers graduelle mais
aussi à des événements extrêmes cros
côtier qui vont devenir de plus en plus
fréquent vont dépendre de l'ampleur du
réchauffement et des actions
d'adaptation permettant de réduire ou de
retarder les risques les systèmes d'
alerte les ouvrages de protection
l'avancé ou le repli planifier les
solutions fondées sur les écosystèmes
côtiers et pour cela comme pour bien
d'autres
aspects liés au changement climatique
les personnes les plus directement
exposés les plus vulnérables qui ont la
moindre capacité à agir
voilà son sont celles dont la capacité
de réponse est la plus faible
les conséquences pour l'océan sont aussi
majeur un océan de plus nos critères de
l'oxygène ans mélangeant - parce qu'il
est plus chaud qui est affectée par
l'acidification a des répercussions sur
la vie marine
sa répartition sa productivité le
potentiel de prises de pêche a déjà
diminué et va continuer à diminuer dans
les régions tropicales les communautés
qui dépendent des produits de la mer
vont être confrontés à des risques pour
leurs revenus pour leur sécurité
alimentaire et parfois pour leur santé
nutritionnelle les options d'action
porte aussi sur la réduction des autres
pressions locales la gestion durable des
pêches
mais aussi les aires marines protégées
pour renforcer la résilience de la vie
dans l'océan et des sociétés qui en
dépendent les conséquences irréversibles
et à long terme pour les sol gelé les
calottes polaires l'océan profond
la montée du niveau des mers souligner
l'urgence à agir de manière ambitieuse
encore donné et tenaces c'est une phrase
exacte dans le dernier rapport spécial
du giec qui a été approuvé par les
représentants de tous les pays
les coûts en matière d'adaptation le
risque de dépasser les limites des
capacités d'adaptation et donc des
pertes et dommages augmente avec le
niveau de réchauffement partout si les
émissions de co2 est émise
instantanément à zéro il n'y aurait
quasiment pas de réchauffement
supplémentaire à l'échelle des
prochaines décennies
mais il ya une inertie dans nos
infrastructures dans le parc de voitures
dans les systèmes de chauffage dans les
usines qui existent aujourd'hui pour
nous donner que quelques exemples
et c'est la vitesse à laquelle nous
serons capables de transformer ses
infrastructures et d'utiliser toutes les
options bas carbone est disponible il va
être clé pour la suite
le niveau de réchauffement à venir va
dépendre des émissions à venir et ce
niveau de réchauffement à venir va
dépendre du cumul des émissions de co2
donc la somme des émissions passées
présentes et futures
et puis de laisser net d autres facteurs
le méthane
site nitreux les particules de pollution
il y aura des tendances inéluctable dans
les prochaines décennies
à cause de l'inertie de nos
infrastructures et des émissions à venir
mais au delà de 2050 à plus long terme
les tendances elles vont dépendre
radicalement des choix qui vont être
haussés partout dans le monde pour les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre à
venir donc la corde paris sur le climat
visent à contenir le réchauffement
largement en dessous de deux degrés et
de renforcer les efforts pour le
contenir à 1 degré ni très très proche
des niveaux actuels
cela ne peut être atteint que si les
émissions mondiales de co2 diminuent
fortement d'ici 2030 an entre 2010 et
2030 un quart de baisse pour se mettre
sur une trajectoire permettant de
limiter le réchauffement en dessous de 2
degrés une baisse de 45% entre 2010 et
2030 ans pour pouvoir le contenir autour
de 1 degré et puis il faut aussi que les
émissions mondiales de co2 atteignent le
net 0 le plus vite possible à cause de
l'effet cumulatif
et ce n'est de zéro c'est dans le monde
entier 2050 pour contenir le
réchauffement d'un degré et demi et 2070
pour le contenir largement dessous de
deux degrés si bien sûr les conditions
nécessaires permettant d'atteindre ses
objectifs
c'est aussi une forte baisse de l'effet
net sur le climat les autres émissions
contenir le réchauffement largement en
dessous de deux degrés sa demande de
mettre en oeuvre des transitions qui
combine adaptation gestion de risque
résilience est décarbonation profonde
dans tous les grands systèmes de
production l'énergie l'utilisation des
terres les villes les systèmes urbains
les systèmes industriels et aussi les
grandes infrastructures nécessaires et
de déployer une large palette de
technologies avec des ruptures récente
qui donne des solutions disponibles
aujourd'hui mais aussi d'agir sur la
demande avec une évolution des
comportements une diminution très rapide
de l'utilisation du charbon dans le
monde
une réorientation des investissements
sortir des énergies fossiles et
augmenter les investissements vers les
options bas carbone et l'efficacité
énergétique avec un besoin en fait de
financement multiplier d'un facteur 5 à
6 à horizon 2050 d'ici à 2050
cela a été dit tout à l'heure mais le
système alimentaire joue un rôle
important
de nombreux leviers d'action tiennent à
ce système alimentaire qui représente
aujourd'hui depuis la production jusqu'à
nos assiettes et aux poubelles
un tiers des émissions mondiales de gaz
à effet de serre il y est très
vulnérable les options d'action elle
porte sur l'élimination des pertes et
gaspillages la transformation des modes
de production de transformation de
consommation et la gestion de risque
parmi ces options d'actions il ya la
diversification des régimes alimentaires
vers une alimentation nutritive est
saine avec plus de protéines végétales
et des systèmes de production parce que
cela favorise l'adaptation contribuer à
une baisse des émissions et permettent
de libérer des terres de réduire la
pression sur les terres pour différents
usages y compris la préservation de la
biodiversité dans les trajectoires qui
correspondent à une stabilisation du
réchauffement largement en dessous de
deux degrés l'élimination de co2 de
l'atmosphère qu'on a déjà mis et
nécessaire pour compenser des émissions
résiduelles ou bien après avoir dépassé
un certain niveau de réchauffement
revenir en arrière par des émissions
nettes négatives c'est à dire on enlève
du co2 atmosphérique certaines options
pour ceux là peuvent apporter de
nombreux qu'aux bénéfices comme la
préservation la restauration le
renforcement des puits naturels de
carbone
mais d'autres options comme la
production à grande échelle de culture
de biomasse pour l'énergie des
monocultures ou de la forêt station
c'est-à-dire planter des forêts à la
place de terre qui avait d'autres usages
cela peut présenter au contraire des
effets indésirables néfaste pour la
biodiversité la sécurité alimentaire la
sécurité en eau bien les droits fonciers
des populations locales
il ya néanmoins un potentiel pour un
déploiement soutenable avec des essences
locales dans une gestion intégrée de
paysages je donne avec ces quelques
exemples
cette cette vision que les enjeux en
matière de changements climatiques et
des multiples dimensions de la
soutenabilité sont intimement liés
chaque option d'action pour s'adapter à
un climat qui change pour faire baisser
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
présente en fait des profils de
synergies ou de compromis avec d'autres
dimensions de là
soutenabilité les dimensions sociales
des dimensions économiques et les autres
dimensions environnementales ça veut
dire en fait que sa demande de ne pas
mettre l'action pour le climat dans un
silo dans une boîte en mai de l'intégrer
dans une vision d'ensemble pour
construire en fait des transformations
profondes qui soit éthique équitable et
juste
ils préservent la biodiversité et les
droits fondamentaux en particulier des
personnes les plus vulnérables et les
plus exposés à la fois un climat qui
change mais aussi aux choix et aux
politiques publiques
agissant pour le climat la faisabilité
de l'action pour le climat en matière de
gestion de risques d'adaptation de
baisses d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre sa demande d'agir sur les systèmes
de production
les profils d'investisseme la demande et
cela de multiples dimensions la
coopération à tous les échelons en fait
de décisions de l'échelle de l'individu
à au territoire où l'on vit l'échelle
nationale européenne et internationale
il ya des enjeux matière majeur en
matière d'éducation de formation de
rapports à la science de se projeter
vers un avenir désirable est souhaitable
il ya des enjeux majeurs en matière
d'innovation d'innovation technologique
l'innovation sociale d'innovation frugal
avec des solutions abordables pour tous
partout et d'innovation en matière de
solutions fondées sur la nature enfin il
ya également des enjeux de mobilisation
de financements
et pour terminer des enjeux de
gouvernance je crois que c'est ce
pourquoi nous sommes réunis la
répartition de la responsabilité la
responsabilité historique
responsabilités actuelles la répartition
des conséquences différentes en du
changement climatique selon les régions
selon les générations selon les
vulnérabilités et les capacités à agir
cela on fait aussi profondément un enjeu
de justice ans et je précise qu'en
france en deux tiers de la population
est exposée directement aux aléas
climatiques
pour terminer en fait les points clés de
ces éléments scientifiques soulignent à
quel point chaque fraction de
réchauffement supplémentaire ou éviter
compte à quel point chaque tonne de gaz
à effet de serre émise ou éviter compte
chaque année et chaque choix compte
et pour terminer pour moi mettre
l'action pour le climat et la
biodiversité au coeur des valeurs de la
république
à côté des règles fondamentales du vivre
ensemble les valeurs de liberté
d'égalité et de fraternité me semble
essentiel merci merci je vais donner la
parole notre rapporteur et guillaume
chevrollier merci monsieur le président
merci madame et messieurs pour vos
interventions c'est toujours passionnant
d'écouté des scientifiques et d'avoir le
président du muséum national naturel qui
est à côté du sénat et qui est un lieu
où vous aviez accueillis pour nous
présenter ce que vous les travaux enfin
les expositions et les travaux menés
dans cette noble institution où il faut
diffuser de la connaissance et le sénat
est là aussi pour objectiver les débats
qui traversent la société et diffuser de
la connaissance hanks et vos
interventions étaient tout à fait
intéressante permettait de les recentrer
un petit peu sur le l'ordre du jour de
notre réunion qui était une table ronde
avec des scientifiques sur le projet de
révision de la constitution avec la
modification de l'article 1 et pour nous
les législateurs avec la grande question
de de la valeur ajoutée 2
de ceux de cette phrase supplémentaires
par rapport à la charte de
l'environnement
si j'osais je dirais est-ce que déjà
depuis 2005 la présence de la charte de
l'environnement
et ici on rajoute cette phrase est ce
que ça serait empêché six avaient été
mis en application plutôt est-ce que ça
va empêcher d extension massive que vous
avez évoqué est ce que ça va empêcher
une dégradation de la biodiversité tels
que vous l'avez parfaitement décrite et
qui nous interpellent et nous mobilise
dans notre travail de législateur sa
petite introduction et après j'ai des
questions extrêmement précises à vous
poser donc considérer vous de votre
point de vue scientifique la phrase qui
nous est proposée par l'exécutif qui
suit les travaux de la convention
citoyenne considérez vous de cette
phrase est satisfaisante
et si vous en tant que scientifique avec
la polyvalence qui vous caractérise si
vous étiez constitutionnaliste si vous
aviez la plume du constituant est ce que
vous auriez plus la même formulation ou
ce que vous proposeriez une formulation
différente
deuxième question est ce que vous êtes
optimiste quant à la possibilité les
pouvoirs publics de satisfaire aux
obligations nouvelles qui leur à combret
si cette révision était adopté en l'état
ils ont classé la révision de la
constitution française est ce que la
france peut garantir seul sur ce sujet
si si vaste
justement l'inscription de ses
obligations au seul niveau national sans
s'appliquer aux autres pays
vous savez vous semble être de nature à
produire des effets mesurables sur la
biodiversité et le climat et la
protection de l'environnement à cette
échelle est elle utile même si un cadre
de coopération internationale n'est pas
organisée même si on sait qu'il ya des
accords internationaux les coop vous en
avez cité coop climat et comme
biodiversité d'ailleurs autre question
l'appréciation par le juge
constitutionnel des efforts menés en
faveur de la protection de
l'environnement vous parait-elle aisé à
évaluer puisque apparemment aussi ça
rend dans le droit positif et ce qu'est
le juge constitutionnel saisi va-t-il
faire une évaluation et quels
indicateurs scientifique pour être pris
en compte
merci monsieur houlgate
merci président merci à vous pour
provost exposé donc on est je dirais
tous convaincus que notre rapport à la
nature doit doit évoluer et même que
nous devons une certaine façon opérer un
changement de paradigme non plus dominer
la nature l'exploiter mais plutôt
coopérer avec elle la respecter et pour
eux mêmes pourraient même aller jusqu'à
dire notre soeur la terre mais ce
changement de relations ne doit pas nous
conduire à une forme de divinisation
parce que la nature a parfois ses
travers et parmi ces travers les
écosystèmes qui abrite la biodiversité
sont donc très vulnérables aux invasions
biologiques et dans le territoire où
j'habite qui est le département de la
manche
je vais vous citer les herbes de la
paume pas je vais vous citer le
chiendent qui colonisent les herbus
littoraux le rat musqué le frelon
asiatique et ainsi de suite
donc ça veut dire qu'à un moment donné
l'homme doit intervenir dans la
régulation etc par rapport à cette
régulation que je voudrais vous vous
questionnez et notamment au regard de ce
que nous allons inscrire
peut-être dans la constitution donc la
france garantit la préservation de
l'environnement et de
la diversité biologique et de la lutte
contre le dérèglement climatique et au
titre de cette diversité biologique
comment vous voyez-vous la main de
l'homme notamment en matière de
régulation
et est-ce qu'elle a sa place ou est ce
que c'est quelque chose qui doit qui
doit être proscrit beau jeu il ya eu des
travaux très très intéressant sur
l'évolution des espèces l'inra de rennes
a fait notamment des travaux sur
l'évolution
comment dire âge de la faune des
vertébrés durant la période de la lho
scène c'est à dire de moins en moins
9200 avant jésus-christ jusqu'à perdre
jusqu'à maintenant et on voit des choses
assez assez tout à fait intéressante
dans ses travaux il ya des espèces qui
ont disparu doutions réapparu etc etc
donc quelle est la place de la main de
l'homme et est ce que cet article dans
la constitution va oui ou non favoriser
ou obérer la possibilité de réguler
merci en visio monsieur jacques merci
merci président laurent caure puis merci
pour vos excellents témoignages je
m'adresse et plus directement en
n'amassant de le mode parce qu'elle est
originaire de nancy et puis on s koné je
loue votre conscience
une des premières auditions de la
commission était d'aider a donc continué
en 2010 année qui est venu au sénat si
on avait eu un échange à la faim et à
cette époque là il y avait encore des
climato-sceptiques et je fais le constat
qu'il n'y a plus de propos climato
sceptiques
en tout cas au parlement je mens détecte
plus le président de l'association des
150 que nous avons auditionné récemment
à a eu ces propos et cette métaphore en
dix ans la chauffant climatique
c'est comme la nation du médecin avec en
fumant et lui dit il faut pas fumer un
jour vous risquez d'avoir un cancer du
poumon
mais le gars il continue à fumer parce
qu'il a une annexion et puis un jour le
médecin alors soit il lui dit bon c'est
fichu on pensait trop tard et j'ai
trouvé ça
assez intéressant en ce que j'ai
vraiment le sentiment que notre affaire
c'est quelque chose comme ça alors je
reprendrai un à masson delmotte
l'expression de notre collègue éminent
tout à l'heure l'homme de thil s'adapter
en lui-même nous présenter des
propositions qui semble intéressante pas
trop effrayante
une limitation qui semble accessible
comment rendre ses propositions et ce
futur véritablement désirable pour en
finir avec cette addiction en au carbone
par exemple et donc ou acquérir
voilà une question très ouverte et je
vous remercie
merci qui souhaitent répondre vous
partager les rôles comme tout à l'heure
évidemment la dernière question allait
plutôt pour valérie la première question
c'était sur la phrase de la constitution
la modification qui est qui est prévu je
peux vous répondre un peu par une
boutade la phrase à l'epa scientifiques
de toute manière non mais c'est vrai et
scientifiquement on a pêché pas j'ai pas
de réponse scientifique en termes de
commentaires scientifiques sur cette
formulation je parle dans une réponse de
citoyens je peux avoir une réponse de
citoyens scientifiques entre guînes
et je pense que c'est souhaitable dans
la mesure où ça participe à une prise de
conscience et que ça pousse aussi vers
une prise de conscience et que sa force
aussi à une certaine action parce que
prendre conscience des choses je pense
que maintenant c'est fait je sais plus
lequel d'entre vous le disait peut-être
que c'est monsieur jacques 1 il ya il a
plus aucun collègue qui soit
climato-sceptiques moi j'appelle ça
klimato négationniste maintenant
d'ailleurs parce que je considère qu'on
a dépassé le stade de scepticisme alors
il peut y en avoir encore quelques uns
mais pour moi ils sont klimato
négationniste carrément voilà aux états
unis il ya un nid l'abaya il ya sans
doute à un nid de klimato négationnistes
donc on l'a prise de conscience elle
existe comment est-ce qu'on passe à
l'action derrière avec une certaine
d'urgence d'action aussi bien pour le
climat et valérie l'a très bien montré
que pour la biodiversité ou la parabole
de la tour eiffel que je vais
t'expliquer tout à leur montrent que ça
va finir par s'effondrer les écosystèmes
vont fonctionner autrement et qui nous
rendront plus du tout les mêmes services
c'est que ça risque d'être vraiment un
au détriment donc comment est-ce qu'on
passe à l'action une phrase comme ça
dans la constitution pour moi c'est
quelque chose qui pousse à l'action
alors après en tant qu'élu vous allez me
dire mais qu'elles variaient rond mais
aussi parce qu'il faut pas que n'importe
quel citoyen un petit peu un petit peu
baroque 10 mais c'est scandaleux que
fait l'état
j'avais j'avais un bout de forêt
derrière chez moi je l'est plus c'est un
scandale enfin bon je vais botté en
touche c'est votre problème mais
il faut savoir aussi mettre mettre
éventuellement ce genre des limites et
puis après je laisserais ma la parole à
mai à mes collègues sur la question de
l'optimisme qui est une question
importante savoir si on est optimiste
s'il ya l'obligation d'action on peut
être un peu plus optimiste que s'il ya
pas obligation d'action bien évidemment
parce que si a pas obligation d'action
il va ça risque de mettre un certain
temps avant qu'il se passe quelque chose
et je puis j'ai peur qu'on soit dans le
mur quand il va vraiment se passer
quelque chose pour la biodiversité ça
sera peut être encore possible de ce
sera peut-être pas tout à fait trop tard
mais pour le climat ça sera vraiment
trop tard
valérie nous a très bien expliqué qu'il
ya une inertie du système dans climat
qui fait que tout ça c'est cumulatif en
plus et que c'est difficile de revenir
en arrière une fois que l'océan va
s'être échauffé il va s'être échauffés
si la circulation change dans l'océan ce
qu'on appelle la circulation
thermohaline sa mère un millénaire à se
rétablir
donc l'optimisme pour la biodiversité
j'aurais tendance à la voir parce que la
biodiversité est très résilient pour
utiliser un mot maintenant qui est passé
dans le langage courant
c'est à dire qu'ils ont envie de la paix
à un moment donné elle va assez bien
réagir tant qu'on n'a pas dépassé un
certain effet de seuil et c'est très
gratifiant puisque si on agit ici et
maintenant on en tire les fruits dans
pas longtemps et à l'endroit où on a agi
c'est un petit peu plus gratifiant pour
le climat même si je dis pas que le plan
climat c'est pas important parce que
sinon arracher un oeil ou les deux c'est
très important aussi d'agir pour le
climat mais quand on agit pour le climat
on sait très bien qu'il ya une inertie
du système qui fait que ça sera visible
dans quelques décennies peut-être et que
ça participe à un climat mondial et que
donc si on est tout seul à agir c'est
moins gratifiant c'est plus difficile
c'est pas pour autant qu'il ne faut pas
le faire je fais souvent l'exemple de
derrière c'est pas parce que des tickets
de métro par terre dans ta dans paris
que je dois jeter mon ticket de métro
par terre même s'il y en a déjà un
million par terre et que ça changerait
pas grand chose si ge est le mien par
terre donc on doit néanmoins agir c'est
parce qu'il doit nous pousser à
l'inaction pour la biodiversité
on ne doit avoir des arguments très
forts parce que si on agit chez nous en
france outre mer ou métropole c'est chez
nous outre-mer et métropole où ça se
verra où il y aura une un retour sur
investissement entre guillemets pour les
citoyens
turon
accepter finalement un certain nombre de
contraintes mais avec finalement des
avantages positifs derrière donc faisons
là c'est ce dont on parlait tout à
l'heure aussi bien le risque que valérie
sur les sujets d'alimentation sur les
sujets derrière l'alimentation c'est les
sujets d'agriculture quelle agriculture
on veut comment est ce qu'on cultive
comment est-ce qu'on se nourrit jusqu'à
quel point on va chercher des poissons
dans la mer quel type de poisson etc
mais je vais laisser la parole à mais
mes collègues pour continuer de répondre
à l'ensemble des questions
allez-y vous pouvez y aller même
oui je vous remercie donc je voudrais
répondre de la même manière que bruno da
ville sur la question de la formulation
je pense que la question n'est pas le
degré de précision de rigueur et de
jargon scientifique c'est sa relève en
fait du jeu du registre ok davantage
juridique et de grand choix de société
pour moi il je peux vivre avec la
formulation telle qu'elle est exprimée
vous avez vu d'ailleurs que dans mon
intervention je n'ai pas utilisé les
mêmes termes
je vois là mais ces termes là sont
utilisés couramment par ailleurs il ya
une question qui était posée c'était
celle du niveau national et par rapport
aux autres pays
alors ya une particularité sur les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
france en il ya celle du territoire
national et puis celles qui tiennent à
nos importations qui représentent en
fait la moitié de l'empreinte carbone de
quelqu'un qui vit en france on avec
trois quarts des leviers d'action par
rapport à cette empreinte qui touche au
cahier des charges des commandes des
acteurs des filières voilà de
distribution des filières industrielles
et donc une action à un endroit donné
alors de préférence coordonnées au
niveau européen c'est le cas en sur les
politiques pour le climat peut avoir des
effets en cascade sur l'ensemble de ces
filières d'approvisionnement avec des
enjeux climat mais aussi des enjeux
biodiversité sur par exemple la
déforestation importés il ya également
une question qui était posée vis-à-vis
de la charte de l'environnement et moi
tel que je le comprends je ne suis pas
du tout juriste
à l'époque c'était nécessaire mais c'est
clairement pas suffisant
on le voit en fait quotidiennement par
exemple
la charte de l'environnement par elle
même n'a pas conduit à évaluer chacune
des lois à l'angle de ses implications
sur l'adaptation à un climat qui change
bien sûr les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre elle n'a pas conduit à depok avoir
une évaluation des budgets au regard des
conséquences pour l'environnement elle
n'a pas conduit à mettre en place une
formation dans l'ensemble du système
éducatif ou bien pour les acteurs pas
d'aidés des collectivités des
fonctionnaires sur ces enjeux là elle
n'a pas conduit à modifier les commandes
publiques pour prendre en compte ces
dimensions
ce sont quelques exemples qui souligne
que c'était je pense nécessaire mais
clairement pas suffisant pour en fait
mettre en place une action qui soit
efficace parce que perçu comme au coeur
des valeurs de la république
et d'ailleurs quand on enseigne à des
enfants les valeurs de la république
aujourd'hui on ne parle pas de la
préservation de l'environnement ce que
je ne comprends pas vraiment je ne
comprends pas ça donne l'impression que
on crée des règles de vivre ensemble qui
sont fondamentales vraiment fondamental
sur ces principes de la république mais
comme si c'était hors sol est déconnecté
en fait des milieux naturels dont nous
dépendons pour toutes
en fait tant pour nos habitats pour
notre alimentation pour nos conditions
de vie voilà alors par ailleurs il y
avait également des questions qui ont
été posées qui qui portait sur les
discours que l'on entend et je veux
mentionner que effectivement on entend
moins en france
des discours de dénis par rapport à des
faits clairement démontré vis-à-vis de
l'influencé de l'homme sur le climat
mais aussi de la sévérité des risques
mais je dirais que on voit évoluer ses
discours dans le déni au départ vers des
discours de l'inaction il ya en fait des
chercheurs en sciences sociales qu ont
cartographié les discours les plus
fréquents par rapport à l'inaction
le premier en fait c'est de dire ce
n'est pas nous ne faisons rien ou bien
la responsabilité celle des autres donc
se dédouaner de ses propres
responsabilités
cela peut porter sur aussi reporté la
responsabilité vers les individus et non
pas vers l'organisation les règles
je le cadre réglementaire juridiques qui
s'imposent à tous il ya également un
discours qui est celui de baisser les
bras
le changement c'est impossible à quoi
bon il est trop tard c'est va pas assez
vite on est déjà dans une situation très
grave
c'est un discours en fait d'inaction
parce qu'il met l'accent non pas sur ce
que l'on peut faire
mais sur ce qui nous échappe il ya
également un discours de l'inaction qui
met l'accent sur les effets indésirables
par exemple chercher un perfectionnisme
sur les politiques publiques plutôt que
mettre en place de manière assez
pragmatique ce qui peut être fait et
enfin un dernier type de discours de
l'inaction portent sur des actions qui
soient en fait non transformative par
exemple simplement des encouragements et
pas d'obligation et donc c'est très
connu en fait c'est ça existe partout
dans le monde en france comme ailleurs
dans tous les contextes et je pense que
c'est important de pouvoir comprendre
ses discours de l'inaction qui en fait
ne vise qu'une chose d'assez repousser
des transformations profondes qui sont
indispensables si l'on veut pouvoir agir
aussi bien aux bénéfices du climat qu'à
celui de la biodiversité
vous me posez la question je crois si
j'étais de ma patience j'ai une patience
infinie léger aussi en fait une
frustration énorme
pourquoi parce que le constat sur le
climat ils datent des années 1970 quand
je suis né les éléments scientifiques
vis-à-vis de l'influencé de l'homme sur
le climat se sont construits se sont
renforcés dans les années 80 le premier
rapport du giec est sorti j'étais au
lycée
ce constat n'a fait que ça ciné se
renforcer et malgré ce qui existait déjà
en sept ans les cadres différents on
voit bien qu'il n'était pas adapté
on voit bien que malgré les négociations
internationales les engagements qui ont
été pris on peine à agir à hauteur de
ses engagements et à hauteur des enjeux
donc ça demande en fait vraiment de
réfléchir profondément à à des
changements structurels profonds qu'ils
et qui finalement construisent le cadre
dans lequel on fera les choses autrement
et je reviens sur la question de la
constitution j'ai interrogé in de messi
qui est étudiante qui a fait des études
de droit c'est pas mon cas et elle m'a
expliqué en fait la manière dont les
cons
qui tu chantes des différents pays ont
été construites en l'importance
finalement deux de ses valeurs
fondamentales dans le cadre juridique et
quand ça a été mis en place au moment de
la révolution française ou dans l'après
guerre les différentes révisions de la
constitution
ces enjeux environnementaux n'ont pas
été intégrés il n'était pas connu
ils n'ont pas été mis en place à hauteur
d hauteur de ce que l'on voit très
clairement aujourd'hui et des enjeux de
transformation nécessaire et voilà il
avait un dernier point a oui qu'est ce
qu'on entend par préservation de
l'environnement
donc pour moi en fait ça touche à la
question des écosystèmes et de la
biodiversité
ça touche aux questions liées au climat
ça touche également aux questions qui
touchent qui porte sur la qualité de
l'eau et la qualité de l'air
je vous en prie oui merci vavrille bruno
voit déjà répondu à pas mal de choses
alors jusqu'à que quelques points de ma
part je suis d'accord avec bruno à la
phrase c'est pas scientifique mais c'est
pas trop important ça l'important c'est
que ça pousse à une prise de conscience
ça c'est très important c'est un très
bon signe de la france je considère il
va vers une sensibilisation vers le
grand public qui est très important vers
les nos concitoyens pour comprendre que
voilà le problème
climat biodiversité c'est le problème
principal de nos jours ça marque
vraiment ça met en évidence
ce point très très clairement très
fortement ça c'est très important au
niveau de sensibilisation vers le grand
public je pense pour la plupart des gens
il s'inquiète pas trop du climat de la
terre de la biodiversité ils sont plutôt
occupé pour s'inquiéter autre chose donc
il y a beaucoup de travail à faire pour
au niveau de sensibilisation du grand
public
de l'autre côté ce message c'est aussi
le message vers l'international très
important d'accord de paris ç'a déjà
bien marquer le terrain de l'intérêt de
de l'importance que la france donne à
cette prise de conscience et donc c'est
un message vers l'international très
important je trouve donc tout ça c'est
très important
il y a pourtant une travaillant pourtant
à faire pour expliquer les liens entre
biodiversité et climat il y a encore
beaucoup de confusion la biodiversité
c'est quoi bruno il a parlé un peu de ça
aussi le public s'est pas vraiment
qu'est ce que c'est la biodiversité et
les liens entre les bus biodiversité et
le climat s'est pas trop évident pour
nous en tant que scientifique
c'est net et clair pour pour nos
concitoyens il ya encore beaucoup de
clarifications à faire dans ce sens le
trouveur de faire comprendre que en fait
la biodiversité crise la biodiversité
crise crise climatique c'est en fait
deux faces le même de même problème
c'est pas c'est pas clair dans la tête
des citoyens à mon avis encore donc
voilà
[Musique]
je pensais aussi important passer un
message optimiste car en fait il y à une
normande opportunités face à ce problème
de nos jours il ya des opportunités
surtout pour les jeunes il faut être
créatif
il faut trouver les solutions donc ça
c'est un peu différent par rapport aux
dernières décennies on était plutôt
business as usual c'est ça le monde
comment ça fonctionne le système
économique c'est comme ça aujourd'hui on
a des défis défis importants et je pense
les jeunes ils sont prêts à voile à
trouver les solutions
ça peut être pour ce qui concerne
l'alimentation ça peut être
décarbonisation des industries dans le
transport ça peut être l'élimination de
co2 de l'atmosphère
donc il ya énormément d'opportunités
donc c'est pas du tout une on n'est pas
du tout dans une situation de
catastrophe fin du monde
négativisme cette fois il faut il ya de
bonnes manières de présenter la crise
aussi comme des opportunités mais pour
ce qui concerne le la main de l'homme
dont l'environnement
c'est vrai que nous en nos interventions
en suivant les contrées fait on essaie
de on identifie une problèmes
d'environnement on essaie de régler le
problème avec le biocontrôle
introduction d'une espèce en modifiant
quelque chose dans l'environnement
la plupart des fois ça marche pas il ya
un autre problème qui émerge qu'il faut
régler ensuite
donc on n'est pas trop bien dans nos
interventions jusqu'au présent mais mais
en tout cas on a appris les choses je
pense on comprend beaucoup mieux comment
ça fonctionne là le monde naturel et
comment ça fonctionne le système terre
est le rapport entre le vivant est là le
système terre donc je pense s'il ya des
des manières de d'intervenir dans
l'environnement à envisager dans
l'avenir surtout le fait qu' on
comprends je lui que tout est connecté
comme touche quelque chose il va avoir
les emplois les impacts sur autre chose
on ne maîtrise tout ça beaucoup mieux
aujourd'hui je trouve donc la main de
l'homme c'est toujours important dans
l'environnement
même s'il faut comprendre que
ça n'existe aucune endroit christine
aujourd'hui partout dans le monde c'est
toucher parlons juste au niveau de
concentration de co2 pour louer dans
l'atmosphère il n'existe aucun endroit
naturel même au fond de l'option il y a
énormément de micro plastiques aussi de
arrive là et sera donc notre rôle c'est
de préserver la biodiversité de
préserver la nature il faut il faut
réfléchir à ce que ça veut dire
car ce n'est pas du tout une nature
créée avant que d'hommes est arrivé sur
terre nous avons déjà modifier
énormément de choses donc les réflexions
sont importants je pense dans ce sens-là
de comprendre où et comment intervenir
dans la préservation de l'environnement
il n'y a pas de solution simple miracle
pas du tout au rien réflexion merci je
ne sais pas s'il ya d'autres questions
mais merci franchement merci pour ce
post à paris n'avait pas vu monsieur
favreau et madame fait autorisé monsieur
le président mais bien entendu nous rien
pragmatique je me tournerai vers madame
masson delmotte qui nous a parlé tout à
l'heure des différents discours qui dans
la population du monde entier essayé de
justifier finalement la situation que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui
je crois que le discours le plus courant
qu'on peut entendre quand on prend les
statistiques de production de co2
on sait qu'aujourd'hui trois les trois
pays les plus peuplés au monde
produisent plus de 50% du co2
sur la planète le discours du français
qui aujourd'hui au quotidien et est bien
évidemment sensibiliser sur les
problèmes que vous évoquez tout à
l'heure le discours c'est de dire mais
même si nous faisons des efforts est ce
que dans cinquante ans nos voisins les
plus éloignés les plus gros producteurs
de co2 ne vont pas finalement détruire
tous les efforts que nous aurons fait
chez nous et comme effectivement ça se
passe sur un espace clos qui la planète
je comprends qu'on puisse tenir ce
discours alors je vous pose la question
est ce que vous pensez malgré tout que
nous pourrons nous français si nous
faisons des sacrifices majeurs demain et
bien bénéficié d'une réaction collective
de l'ensemble des pays du monde pour
repayer cette situation merci tv line
perreault oui merci
vendredi j'étais avec des manifestants
agricole et très sincèrement ils sont
très très inquiets pour le
le devenir de leur profession et ce
qu'il ce qu'ils m'ont dit quand vous
dites il faut mieux communiquer je pense
que il ya vraiment une très grande
communication à faire vis-à-vis du monde
agricole et ils ont ils sont partants
pour pour changer les choses ils sont
ils sont partants ils sont conscients du
problème actuel mais ils se sentent
incompris isolé et ils ont vraiment
besoin de travailler avec vous à la
limite et il faut vraiment que que vous
vous rapprochez de ces gens là qui qui
actuellement pâtissent de tous et ont
besoin et seront aussi changer les
choses
accompagné correctement voilà merci je
vous laisse répondre
est-ce que je peux réagir donc par
accueillir les premiers gros oui donc
par rapport au trois premiers grands
émetteurs dans le monde
donc ce sont les états unis la chine et
l'union européenne aujourd'hui donc nous
faisons partie via la stratégie d'action
pour le climat de l'union européenne des
grands émetteurs dans le monde
l'autre point c'est de regarder
également les émissions par habitant à
la fois par rapport au territoire et
aussi par rapport à l'effet des
importations des importations produits
dans des pays utilisant du charbon par
exemple et on voit que quand une
personne moyenne qui vit en france
correspond à au personne qui aime être
le plus de gaz à effet de serre dans le
monde en prenant en compte l'ensemble de
cette empreinte
il ya bien sûr beaucoup plus dans
certains pays mais voilà c'est pour cela
que nous avons une responsabilité à agir
nous avons également une capacité à agir
que j'étais un peu surprise par le terme
sacrifices
c'est intéressant parce que dans les
gens avec lesquels j'interagis dans le
monde des entreprises dans le monde de
la finance
du côté des collectivités locales ou
bien du côté des étudiants les étudiants
dans les grandes écoles
des étudiants dans les universités
auxquelles je suis amené à ces recours
virtuellement cette année fréquemment
c'est pas du tout le terme qui revient
ce qui revient c'est transformation
opportunités emploi qui ont des sens en
poids non délocalisables également cela
fait plutôt partie des termes qui
reviennent le plus souvent est par
ailleurs quand on regarde sur les
transformations à mener en particulier à
l'échelle de la vie personnelle en fait
à l'échelle des choix qu'on va faire
dans sa vie personnelle
il ya trois grandes catégories de choix
pour réduire l'empreinte
environnementale au sens large
il ya des choses qu'on va éviter qu'on
fera moins qu'on fera peut-être plus il
ya des choses qu'on déplace c'est à dire
on a les mêmes
par exemple les mêmes déplacements et on
les fait autrement donc on le déplace et
puis il ya des choses qu'on améliore par
exemple améliorer l'efficacité
énergétique améliorer l'efficacité
l'isolation d'un logement et moi je
parle pas de sacrifice en
personnellement jamais est ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de comprendre ce qu'on
peut améliorer et comment le faire ce
qu'on peut déplacer c'est à dire vivre
bien mais en réduisant l'empreinte
environnementale mais aussi avoir une
conversation sur ce qu'on ne sait plus
on fait ce qu'on ne sait plus parce que
c'est extrêmement néfaste pour
l'environnement
voilà je dirais que je regarde les
choses plutôt de cette manière là dans
un contexte où on voit que par exemple
même pendant la pandémie de l'année
dernière les grandes multinationales qui
étaient les plus engagés pour la
transition énergétique par exemple sont
celles qui ont eu les meilleurs
résultats c'est à dire elle était plus
résiliente même dans un contexte de
crise et donc pour moi en fait ce que
vraiment la question de sens et comment
ce projet tu commences projette non pas
maintenant sur des transformations qui
sont compliquées a mené on le voit bien
mais dans dix ans dans le même temps
qu'est ce qu'on veut avoir construit
qu'est ce qu'on va voir construire
ensemble qui nous permettra d'avoir
apporté notre pierre à l'action
collective de tous les pays du monde
mais aussi avoir construit des filières
agricoles des filières industrielles des
communautés humaines en france qu'ils
soient résiliente avec des emplois qui
ont du sens durable et avec les
compétences qui vont
avec cela voilà je le vois vraiment
d'une autre manière et c'est cela c'est
à cela que je les associe également le
changement dans cet article de la
constitution
c'est quelque chose pour moi qu'il se
projette vers l'avenir c'est pas quelque
chose que je vois comme un sacrifice
mais quelque chose comme une
construction une autre forme de
construction de vivre ensemble de
manière plus apaisée par rapport aux
conséquences de nos actions pour
l'environnement et le dernier point
portait sur le monde agricole
donc je précise que quand j'ai co
superviser le rapport du giec qui
portait sur l'utilisation des terres
dans un climat qui change
on a beaucoup travaillé avec la yahoo
donc l'organisation pour l'agriculture
et l'alimentation mondiale où la france
est très très fortement représenté on a
bénéficié également de des changes
indirects moi j'ai participé à des
réunions avec des acteurs du monde
agricole dans la région parisienne où je
vis mais aussi dans d'autres endroits où
pays basque en lorraine j'ai présenté ce
rapport à des acteurs du monde agricole
directement en montrant l'ensemble des
enjeux qui connaissent très bien parce
qu'ils sont aux premières loges en fait
les températures à 45° d'été les
inondations à des saisons bizarre ou
bien ou bien les sécheresses ils vivent
vraiment première ligne et puis aussi
les effets indirects avec des hivers
plus doux et donc des infestations
différentes de ravageurs voilà qui
n'était pas forcément présent
précédemment ils sont vraiment en
première ligne ils ont aussi conscience
des transformations ils ne font que ça
je pense dans ce secteur ils sont
beaucoup plus dans la transformation
constante et est tel que je le comprends
les enjeux qui les expriment aujourd'hui
j'ai échangé aussi avec la fnsea
dans ce contexte là avec la
confédération paysanne il ya eu tout un
manifeste qui a été fait par l'asn et
soa par rapport aux solutions qu'ils
peuvent porter vis-à-vis de l'action
pour le climat
je crois que la question c'est
l'évolution l'évolution aussi d'aider z
qui sont portés les aides actuelles ont
été analysés au niveau par exemple de la
politique agricole commune et il ya eu 2
nombreux bénéfices à ces aides mais il
ya eu aussi des des effets indésirables
en particulier qui touchait à la qualité
de l'eau qui touchait à aux enjeux
portant sur la dégradation des
écosystèmes et de la biodiversité
et puis des enjeux aussi qu'ils
portaient aux émissions de gaz à effet
de serre donc la question n'est pas à
temps je pense le fait de comprendre les
enjeux
mais c'est plutôt de construire avec eux
une évolution des systèmes de
subventions qu'ils soient le plus juste
possible et c'est un défi majeur
c'est vraiment un défi majeur ah oui
j'ai oublié de dire une chose
donc moi je supervise en ce moment le
prochain rapport du giec on va rendre
cet été au milieu de l'été qui porte sur
l'état du climat à l'échelle globale et
aussi à l'échelle régionale et toutes
les caractéristiques d'un climat qui
change dans chaque région du monde et en
danse les extrêmes les valeurs au dessus
de ce seuil dont penser aujourd'hui
qu'ils provoquent des dommages beaucoup
de ces seuils touche à la production
agricole
parce qu on est déjà dans une situation
où ce climat qui change affectent la
production agricole partout dans le
monde
en france comme ailleurs est donc en
fait on
ce qu'on essaie de faire c'est de
construire un accès le plus facile
possible à cette information climatique
avec par exemple un atlas interactif qui
permettra à de nombreux décideurs de
nombreux utilisateurs de cette
information de se l'approprier et de
l'intégrer en complément de tout ce qui
est fait en matière de services
climatiques et de travail directs par le
monde académique en fronçant avec les
acteurs du monde agricole
ce sont des choses qui se font déjà mais
qui mériterait vraiment d'être d'être
renforcée et soutenu ce qu'on voit c'est
que pour soutenir les transformations et
d'action il ya vraiment besoin de
co-construction c'est à dire d'avoir mal
et ceux qui ont besoin de l'information
pour le climat qui travaille avec ceux
qui font des recherches plus académique
pour définir en fait le besoin de
production de connaissances et pour le
partage de connaissances qui soit utile
par rapport à la prise de décision ce
sont des choses qui sont pas forcément
soutenu à hauteur de ce que cela
pourrait être dans le cadre des
financements publics de la recherche
le travail de co-construction il surtout
un travail qui décloisonne entre les
différents domaines académiques ça était
peut-être un peu souligné tout à
or mais on a besoin de faire travailler
ensemble des gens qui vendent la
recherche fondamentale sur le climat
mais aussi des gens qui vont travailler
sur la dimension sociale
la dimension de sciences sociales liées
à ces à ces transformations et les
acteurs de terrain ne manque en fait de
cadres on voit se mettre en place des
actions au niveau des territoires par
exemple les groupes type groupes
régionaux d'experts climat mais qui ont
vraiment besoin d'être renforcée et
soudé parce que c'est souvent à cette
échelle là que se font les échanges les
plus fructueux merci voulait apporter
des compléments ou complément à ses
généraux pour le coup je serais plus
optimiste que valérie masson-delmotte je
pense qu'il ya des choses qui se font
peut-être parce que je suis au muséum
mais il ya beaucoup d expérience de
science participative de projet de
science participative qui voit le jour
qui entraîne des citoyens et je peux
vous dire qu'on a un projet en cours
fac est plus qu'un projet qui est en
route un qui est justement d'aborder les
questions de science participative de
manière transversale autour d'une
question donnée et à travers une filière
qui est justement la filière agricole où
on par des horticulteurs des maraîchers
des agriculteurs des citoyens qui ont
leur jardin
de toutes ces choses là et donc on
interroge des citoyens sur leurs
pratiques sur comment ils font sur
qu'est ce qu'ils perçoivent sur comment
ça marche
donc c'est vraiment une expérience
filière métier en quelque sorte de
science participative qui touche
l'agriculture et j'entends que les
agriculteurs soient tu as compris se
trouve que l'autre jour j'ai été
auditionné à l'assemblée nationale sur
la question des grands prédateurs en
france donc la présence du loup la
présence de l'ours enfin des choses
comme ça et on voit bien que on est dans
une logique d'affrontement
comme l'a dit par contre valérie on ne
sortira pas de on ne résoudra pas ce
genre de problème très large ou au
contraire spécifique si on sort pas de
cette logique d'affrontement
donc il faut qu'on accepte de briser les
barrières de de casser les barrières
et d'avancer ensemble on a une grande
question à résoudre qui pose derrière
elle une multitude d'autres questions
qui et comment est ce que on habite la
terre quelle éthique pour la planète
le ton est pour nos territoires à
commencer par nos territoires sont les
gueules soyons égoïste un commençons par
nous a d'abord commençons par nos
territoires et ça pousse tout de suite
derrière la question des limites quelles
sont les limites qu'on accepte de se
donner
sachant que nous sommes dans un monde
fini c'est bien connu il ya des limites
les limites elles font partie
intrinsèquement de la vie moi je suis
partie biologiste je travaillais sur
l'évolution l'évolution une leçon de
limites
nous ne sommes pas adapté à vivre à 300
mètres de profondeur
d'ailleurs si on y va on va pas être
bien donc on voit bien qu'on a des
limites
il ya des limites tiens tout le temps
des limites et l'espèce humaine étant à
repousser ses limites jusqu'à l'extrême
jusqu'à toucher les murs et maintenant
il faut savoir comment est-ce qu'on gère
ses limites quelles limites au
consumérisme quelles limites à nos
ambitions et nos comportements
puisque ça me nuit aussi à nous mêmes
donc ça revient à la formule que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure l'homme
sera-t-il s'adapter à lui même c'est on
est on en est vraiment là donc il est il
est temps d'agir et je trouve que
modifier la constitution c'est un signal
très fort qui est donnée comme le disait
crise c'est un signal pour la france
mais c'est aussi un signal à
l'international qui va dans le sens qui
dépasse la prise de conscience et qui
doit pouvoir pousser à l'action après en
mettant d'autres limites pour éviter que
ça dérape effectivement et qu'on se
retrouve dans des situations qui serait
totalement ingérable bien évidemment
même et je pense que c'est un signal
fort s'est alors c'est peut-être trop
emphatique de le dire comme ça mais pour
moi c'est un petit peu comme la
déclaration des droits de l'homme que je
veux dire la france peut s'enorgueillir
d'avoir écrit ce texte au moment de la
révolution française on pourrait
s'enorgueillir d'avoir écrit ça dans la
constitution française est le premier
peut-être pays au monde à l'inscrire
dans sa constitution de manière aussi
claire
est-ce que je peux juste ajouter un
point et on a tout le monde parlait un
peu le qu'il faut mieux dialoguer entre
entre entre nous il faut mettre ensemble
des différents acteurs c'est tout à fait
nécessaire de casser les barrières entre
les disciplines
je pense le point de départ de tout ça
c'est l'éducation qu'il faut sortir un
peu de poids zone mans dont l'éducation
car typiquement un enfant qu'il commença
le parcours scientifique il reste la
science pour toute sa carrière quand il
commence littéraire il sort plus et il
faudra avoir un peu plus de souplesse
dans le système éducation pour pour que
tout le monde peuvent accepter peut
accéder plusieurs disciplines pour
qu'ils peuvent acquérir les notions
scientifiques les notions de sciences
sociales les notions de gouvernance
il n'y a pas vraiment une science de
l'environnement l'environnement ce n'est
pas un discipline c'est une à ces
quelques choses beaucoup plus difficiles
à définir et les gens qui travaillent
dans dont l'environnement il faut que
qui maîtrisent peu les notions physiques
chimiques écologiques comment ça
fonctionne le climat mais également
gouvernance si on social et c'est
difficile dans le système actuel je
trouve par exemple conditionne qu'une
scientifiques arrivent dans le monde
politique
donc ça sera très important à mon avis
que qu'on commence à aa a décloisonné un
peu les disciplines pour que les gens
peuvent accéder différentes notions
peuvent maîtriser mieux
qu'est ce que c'est l'environnement
quels sont les enjeux
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire au niveau
scientifique au niveau si on social
gouvernance etc
je trouve ça c'est important
[Musique]